what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here is John over here so today we're
gonna watch from America's Got Talent
Damien Aditya escape artist risked his
life during his audition I'm excited to
see this a lot of people I've been
sending over these America's Got Talent
videos to us one sound people a lot of
talented people but before we get into
this video we wanted to give a shout out
to today's sponsor who we're very
excited to be actually talking about
today because it's gonna allow us an
opportunity to do something we've wanted
to do for a while which is give back to
some charities and engage with you guys
more directly as well yes so there's
this new app out there it's called camp
fire and what camp fire does basically
through a small donation right now we're
just set at three dollars you get to ask
us specific questions and mmediately 50%
of that will go to a charity the charity
that we chose this year is for American
Red Cross all donations will be going
towards the hurricane Harvey Relief and
what's cool though is when you ask us
these specific questions you'll get an
audio message from us that I'll go
directly to your phone so you get a have
audio of us answering your question on
your phone if your questions popular
enough if it's a question fellow users
are craving for answer too you can get
paid for asking it so yeah guys this
opportunity is really cool because it's
a win-win situation for everyone it
allows you guys a chance to earn money
allows us to get 50% of the earnings
automatically will go directly towards
them and it'll be another addition to us
being able to give back with the help of
you guys of course so please go download
the campfire app join the community you
know shoot us some questions and help us
support a good cause let's have a
conversation about some time to be a
good influence or a life you know
anyway meantime let's watch this
what's your name my name is Damien what
are you gonna be doing here tonight we
have a dangerous I thought I want to
show you guys how long have you been
doing this this one is the second one
what this is a very dangerous escape
back yes why what could happen he could
die
yes you're being serious it's seriously
I would be locked up from ankles wrists
and then we only afraid the cover above
me I have two minutes to a stiff before
900 top of San above that crossed the
cover and buried me alive so believe it
worth risking your life for this or I
think I got that yes my wife is watching
caught on the side and probably it's not
going to look because you always afraid
oh my god she's terrified well obviously
he survives right there was this would
it be on television no no we leave it on
not squeamish here
Wow that dedication to your craft
sharp haircuts I wonder if she's part of
the act like she's supposed to act
terrified you know
I have like chills man it's really
intense like a good escape
[Music]
what how is he gonna get out of that
these judges are sure supportable he's
going to fail guys
[Music]
sneaking
I'm gonna cry I'm scared oh geez
is it miss me Amy emotional is his wife
as well it's hard to the actress clever
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
well now it's cool cuz anybody could
have just gotten out of the change man
the way you do dragons I'm so sick of
these guys but yeah very sick of like
that smile and toothpick combo didn't
change once that videos way we gotta
rewind this back just a tad bit the
white has to be like part of the act
so they come from the right one there's
some kind of obstacle thing happening
yeah he's handed that can't he can't
actually be in there when it's happening
cuz he comes from the right well I mean
he must disappear on their back or maybe
some guy goes in the back and then he
switches out with him yeah but I feel
like the the chamber through which the
sand falls is not oh but these say yeah
death or whatever there's nothing
odd-looking about that contraption but
it's still a super great illusion trick
he can't really actually be trapped in
there and all that's going on it has I
don't think this would really be life
like so dangerous that we can't yes yeah
that was the case it wouldn't be it has
to be some type of illusion trick
obviously brilliantly done because I did
not see that coming I was like okay he's
not gonna get out of this so the sounds
gonna fall is gonna appear from behind
or something to come from the right side
of the stage it come running on that was
that was brilliantly done boy that's
impressive I love that dedication of
passion makes me think makes me wish I
could do something more important with
my life starting well you know what you
know you know it's important the
campfire rap it's not an escape but it's
good to give - yeah it's good to give to
charity and you know don't forget you
guys could get paid for asking us a
question - that's our way of being up to
par with this escape artist right yeah
that's our Houdini yeah that's our Dini
is 50% of the money will go scape
to a charity of our choice that's
probably the most qualitative is yeah
way to go neva did not be covered in the
sand when he gives me yeah this guy
should be in the raid movies yeah yeah
yeah I have like an escape sequence one
big Throwdown of a fight and then also
just want to see more guy gets chained
up it's really hard from to get out I
think his wife's totally and on the act
has to act terrified and like be a
fearful person it has to be a part of
the Act I've seen various escape
routines on different magic shows and
stuff like that and for some reason
people always look realistically work so
I almost wonder if there is a certain
element of this that is parallel cuz
she's just really convincing and it
seems like whoever's filling that role
of the onlooker who's terrified for you
every one of these bits always looks
pretty convincingly horrified that I
don't she's the actress man that's her
job that was a very very impressive you
know different life I wish I could be a
magician or an escape artist or some
kind of so it just seems like the
strangest most impressive Josie the most
attractive job ever what do you do I get
chained up and you escape and you never
see it coming I don't die for a living
yeah well guys thanks for sending that
our way this America's Got Talent videos
are fantastic
I appreciate America's Got Talent at
least letting us have the video up
whenever you include it the video
immediately not monetized but I'm really
happy they at least allow us to keep it
up on YouTube you know yeah yeah I don't
want you to show on TV but you know
seeing little snippets here and there is
actually a lot of fun yeah definitely
it's the base reliance included yeah you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell followed at
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
and like we mentioned before please go
ahead and download that campfire app
follow us ask us some questions ask us
some questions possibly get paid for
asking us some questions and help us get
back to some charity as well so thank
you guys
link in description box looking forward
to those questions my friend
I want to whisper yeah